video games have come a long way over
the years we've gone from the days of
atari and pong to virtual reality
headsets ps5s and massive multiplayer
online games where you can fight horror
movie villains or wage war in a
fantasyland you can mine virtual
minerals and avoid creepers in minecraft
compete against people all over the
world in fortnite and do whatever it is
people do in roblox games used to be a
pixelated hero battling blobby monsters
with no discernible facial features and
now they have graphics so detailed you
can see the freckles on a protagonist's
face and each individual blade of grass
but there's one thing that hasn't
changed no matter how much progress
games may make whenever a shiny new
console comes out everyone wants to get
their hands on it it was christmas
season in 1986.
walk like an egyptian by the bengals was
at the top of the charts eddie murphy's
the golden child was the number one
movie in america and hundreds of
thousands of kids were writing to santa
and begging their parents for one thing
the nintendo entertainment system the
nes was an 8-bit home video game console
and the only place to journey through
the land of hyrule in the legend of
zelda or help samus hunt space pirates
in metroid but with such an extreme
demand for the system stores were
selling out all over the country anyone
who didn't beat the crowds was doomed to
disappoint their kids with socks with
less flashy toys like dolls or tiny
plastic trucks or with boring
non-electric violence-free board games
well board games are only violence free
if you're not playing monopoly but back
to 1986 beverly harrington was a single
mom doing her best to provide for her
son jason and give him the christmas he
deserved she had been picking up extra
shifts at the local diner making sure to
save up all the extra money for a real
christmas tree from the farm just out of
town for a beautiful honey-baked ham and
of course for presents she knew that
though he was a shy kid and would never
demand it jason desperately wanted to
find an nes under the tree on christmas
morning she got so absorbed in her work
so exhausted from the extra shifts and
trying to make everything perfect that
she forgot to do her actual shopping
until the very last minute she woke up
the morning of december 24th with a
start her heart jumping into her throat
she hadn't picked up jason's present yet
she threw on her coat and rushed out
into the snowy streets making her way to
the store and saying a silent prayer
that they would still have one more nes
in stock lucky for her they did less
lucky two parents were already wrestling
for it fighting each other with a raw
animalistic rage of two wolves competing
for the same piece of meat if she tried
to grab it and join in she could get
hurt or the console could break apart
she asked an employee if they had any in
the back but she already knew the answer
from the exhausted look in his eyes
there were no more in the back there
were no more in town nor the next town
over or the next town over from that not
only would she have to get jason's
present at the very last minute but she
would also have to get him something he
didn't even want he would smile and
thank her but she knew how sad it would
make him to go back to school and hear
his friends bragging about their
christmases she shoved her hands into
the pockets of her coat and began her
slow sad march back through the snow
trying to come up with what to do next
then something caught her eye a brightly
colored sign reading wondertaining toys
beneath it it was a storefront she had
never seen before and right there in the
window a video game console it wasn't
the nes not exactly but it looked so
much like it she couldn't help herself
she had to go inside and get a better
look the store was filled with toys
games and puzzles they were all inviting
with vivid packaging and labels
depicting children having fun but she
had never seen any of them before
perhaps it was a new brand and she was
one of the first people to happen upon
the store it seemed odd for a toy store
to open this close to christmas rather
than taking advantage of the shopping
season and opening earlier in the year
but she couldn't dwell on that not when
she was this close to a solution toward
the back of the store she spotted the
video game console from the window the
label read pretendo so the resemblance
to the nes was no coincidence this
console was intended as a knockoff of
some kind she asked the sales clerk a
man with a strangely wide unmoving smile
if the console was capable of running
nintendo games you bet your bottom
dollar he replied we don't carry those
here though but can i interest you in
some of our wondertainment originals we
have all kinds of games here and they're
just as good or your money back there's
a whole world inside each and every one
it wasn't what she'd set out to buy but
this was clearly the best thing beverly
was going to find this close to the
holiday she paid the man for the
pretendo console and a selection of the
store's most popular video games he even
gift wrapped it for her in a colorful
box with a shiny red bow on top the next
morning jason and beverly sat in the
living room sipping cocoa and opening
presents together she started small with
a classic pair of new wool socks and
worked her way up to the big box in the
corner as jason tore the paper off his
eyes lit up with glee thank you mom
thank you he gave her a huge hug then
looked at her with nearly manic
excitement can i play it now can i she
laughed and promised that after he
helped her clean up the wrapping paper
he could play his new games she was just
so glad he was happy with it he didn't
care that it wasn't the name brand
console he knew that this gift was
special so she was perfectly glad to let
him enjoy it and she could get started
on that ham for later jason plugged in
his brand new pretendo and looked
through the games his mom had picked out
for him there was farmtastic farming
simulator historical house hunter magic
wizard quest super fighters and one
simply called spooky it was emblazoned
with the image of a cartoon ghost in
front of an abandoned cabin and it
piqued jason's interest he always loved
scary stories and legends about ghosts
and things that go bump in the night he
decided that this would be the first
game that he would play he placed the
cartridge in the console and hit the
power button to turn it on as he
clutched the controller in his hands he
began to notice something strange his
room once decorated in posters of his
favorite movies turned dark the light
green walls became rotting wood and for
lack of a better way to describe it the
entire world's resolution began to shift
if the world around him had graphics
they were getting worse he could no
longer see the screen depicting the
game's main menu and in fact the console
itself had vanished somehow he was
standing in the haunted cabin from the
cover of the game he looked down at his
hands and found the controller still
there so
not everything had changed before he
could think any more about this strange
new place he found himself in he heard
the sound of ominous music seemingly
coming from nowhere after a moment he
realized why the sound of its melody
filled him with dread it was the kind of
music that always played in the game
when an enemy was getting close he had
to move he took a step forward and moved
through the space as if it was a real
house for the time being it was
somehow he was inside the game which
meant the ghost was coming for him soon
he pressed a button on the controller to
activate a flashlight and followed its
beam through the darkened cabin as he
walked looking for clues or any object
he could interact with he could hear the
music getting louder whatever was coming
it was getting closer the flashlight's
beam illuminated the scrap of paper on a
small table he moved to take a closer
look and could just barely make out what
it said they hide in the darkness
find the exit don't stop moving he heard
a sound behind him and the music reached
a deafening volume he whirled around and
saw nothing but the hull in front of him
bending around a corner he knew from the
heavy feeling in the pit of his stomach
and the music that threatened to rupture
his eardrums that there was something
horrible waiting for him around that
corner he froze for a moment then
remembered the letter's words of warning
don't stop moving he took a step towards
the corner then another and another he
shone the light of the flashlight around
the corner but there was nothing there
no ghost no monster nothing and then he
felt it a chill on the back of his neck
he whirled around and there it was the
ghost of the cabin it was so much bigger
than it had looked before wispy white
form stretching up to the ceiling from
wall to wall its wide dark eyes and
gaping maw of a mouth inches from his
own face he screamed and instinctively
swung the flashlight at the spirit
cutting through it with a beam of light
the ghost let out a shriek and shrink
away from the glow that was it he just
needed to keep the light on it and the
ghost couldn't hurt him jason was so
thrilled by this little victory that he
didn't even notice the boss music
starting to play again growing louder
and louder he didn't see the movement
out of the corner of his eye the silvery
pale figure of a woman stepping out of a
portrait on the wall all he felt was a
sudden overwhelming cold like ice in his
veins and then everything went black he
opened his eyes back in his bedroom
looking at a dark screen with the words
game over written in dripping red font
he couldn't tell for a moment if that
had been real or a dream but either way
he only wanted to do one thing tell his
mom beverly listened to her son's story
and couldn't help but write it off as
the overactive imagination of a child
but still she humored him and agreed to
try the console for herself and see what
happened choosing at random she selected
farmtastic and pressed play all of a
sudden she felt the heat of the sun on
her face heard the mooing of cows and
smelled fresh cut hay she was steering a
tractor through a wide open field where
a moment ago she had been standing in
her house in the dead of winter jason
shut off the game pulling her back into
reality and as beverly gasped in shock
jason said
best present ever unfortunately for
jason word was already spreading about
the pretendo all the way to the scp
foundation the console and all other
consoles that the foundation could track
down were seized and designated scp-591
scp-591 is a line of video game consoles
originally developed as a counterfeit of
the nintendo entertainment system before
being bought and distributed by dr
wondertainment a toy company responsible
for a wide variety of anomalous objects
contained by the foundation over the
years the console is capable of playing
nes titles as well as games from dr
wondertainment's original lineup of
8-bit games many of which the foundation
has in its possession as well some of
the titles in the scp foundation's
library include but are not limited to
arcade shooter wapim platformer dusky's
adventures in stadeland survival horror
game you can do that on television
puzzle game world war one ace trench
digger music racing game led zeppelin
air racers fighting games super kit
karate and super kit karate 2010 and the
educational game reading rainbow sit and
listen whenever one of the official dr
wondertainment cartridges is inserted
into the console and activated it
results in a localized ck-class reality
restructuring scenario which rearranges
reality in the immediate area to
resemble the game's setting the player
inside of the game's affected radius
will take on the role of the game's
protagonist and navigate the events of
the game until either they win or the
console is deactivated don't worry this
isn't one of those if you die in the
game you die in real life scenarios if
the player happens to be a less than
adept gamer they will simply respawn or
start at the beginning of the game like
any video game character would that
doesn't however mean that scp-591
isn't dangerous like any piece of
vintage technology the components of the
pretendo system have degraded over time
their functionality steadily decreasing
for an ordinary game console this would
be a simple inconvenience something that
would impact the quality of the graphics
or responsiveness of the controls it
would be annoying and maybe eventually
unplayable but otherwise harmless for
the pretendo however this degradation
has had catastrophic events when a game
cartridge is inserted into scp-591
there is now a chance of the ck-class
reality restructuring scenario going
wrong and resulting in a zk-class
reality failure scenario instead
essentially instead of just transporting
the player into the world of the game
reality will crumble in the designated
area and the laws of time space and
physics will be bent or even broken
while the ck-class scenarios dissipate
as soon as the console is deactivated
the zk-class scenarios refuse to play by
the rules they remain in place wherever
they first manifested seemingly
permanently the zk class scenarios were
first observed during play testing by
the research staff assigned to
scp-591 after learning about the nature
of the pretendo game system dr furukawa
has volunteered as a test subject
specifically requesting that he be given
the chance to play the dr wondertainment
title the legend of swordmaster because
quote it just looks really cool this
particular game came with not just the
cartridge but a special sword-shaped
controller to be used during the sword
fight sequences dr furukawa stepped into
the containment cell where one instance
of scp-591 had been placed with his
chosen game cartridge and controller
waiting for him as soon as he inserted
the cartridge into the console and
pressed the start button the room around
him began to transform reality itself
warping and reshaping to fit the world
of the game fluorescent lights and stark
white walls were replaced by pixelated
trees and a winding cobblestone path
leading to a massive stone castle the
first enemy a knight in black armor
leapt into frame and dr furukawa raised
his sword ready for combat but before he
had a chance to deal the first blow it
became clear that something wasn't right
the enemy knight suddenly disappeared
glitching out of sight the cobblestone
slowly began to drift into the air and
so did dr furukawa just as suddenly as
he lifted off he dropped back to the
ground with a heavy thud gravity was
rapidly fluctuating and he could
scarcely keep his balance in front of
him he could see random cubic structures
popping up out of nowhere made of wood
stone and ice and the game he called out
desperately pull the plug someone please
outside one of the researchers watching
the experiment cut the power to the
console but nothing happened the world
refused to return to normal security
officers entered the area and attempted
to remove dr furukawa but found that his
body still resembled an 8-bit video game
character when they attempted to drag
him out of the zk-class zone he cried
out in pain as his body began to
dissolve into static they had turned off
the console but they were unable to pull
them out the rest of the research team
horrified by what they had witnessed
began to take measurements of the
reality failure scenario from outside of
the room the area now displayed a
complete absence of naturally occurring
radiation including cosmic background
radiation there was also evidence of
time dilation reduction of light speed
and the gravity fluctuations that dr
furukawa had first noticed with no way
to remove furukawa from this broken
reality the area would have to be sealed
off and he would be left inside there
was no other option so they constructed
a concrete dome around the testing site
and relocated the remaining instances of
scp-591
from that point on testing was only
conducted using d-classes no matter how
much research staff loved video games or
how vehemently they insisted that they
were quote willing to roll the dice they
were barred from testing and encouraged
to pick up a vr headset for a much lower
risk immersive gaming experience over
the years of testing following the dr
furukawa incident four more zk class
scenarios were created and contained
some of the individuals survived the
incident but were physically altered so
greatly that they would not be able to
survive outside of the zk-class reality
failure the only people who survived
were unable to readjust to their lives
continuing to live as the main character
of the game that they were playing
at this point testing was officially
suspended indefinitely due to not only
the loss of human life but also the
unpredictable and highly dangerous
nature of the damage being done to
reality on such a grand scale all
instances of scp-591 confiscated by the
foundation are kept in a storage
containment vault kept separate from any
civilians or their infrastructure by a
distance of at least 500 meters it is
also kept separate from other foundation
containment facilities unless it is
being used for official approved testing
by level 3 staff it is to remain
deactivated at all times any zk-class
scenarios created by an instance of
scp-591 will be contained via the
construction of a closed concrete dome
and given the designation of sector w
number sectors w1 through w5 the
currently existing zk-class scenarios
are monitored remotely and kept highly
classified any personnel or test
subjects located inside one of these
sectors will remain there indefinitely
and be officially considered lost in
action any additional instances of
scp-591 located in civilian stores
households or any public place are to be
removed and contained indefinitely as
the years have gone by testing has
indicated a steady increase in the rate
of zk-class scenarios being generated
from a ck-class scenario where it was
only a one percent chance there is now a
32 chance according to wondertainment
company records seized during a
foundation raid of one of their toy
factories there are still plenty of
scp-591 instances out there in the world
just waiting for some unsuspecting gamer
to fire them up and get lost in the
story literally if the documents found
are accurate there are around 243
consoles and 1300 consoles still in
circulation these also may or may not
include a pocket pretendo model that was
developed as a prototype but never
officially released on the market if it
was and the chaos of the pretendo system
is available in a portable form well
it's best not to think about that for
too long the foundation is doing its
best to track down the remaining
pretendo systems but there is no way to
know for sure what distant corners of
the world they've made their way to so
when you're picking up a shiny new game
console or a nostalgic vintage model to
relive some of your favorite childhood
memories with take an extra close look
at the label and make sure you're
getting the real thing because if you're
not careful it just might be game over
now go check out
scp-1007 mr life and mr death at scp-001
a simple toy maker my favorite episode
for more on the weird whimsical world of
dr wondertainment